when
java the bell no sweat now feeling swell
you down it's a beautiful day gonna burn
my truck I'm going
I'm the wall
the bus now
hello everyone and welcome to the
fallout 4 show christmas edition because
it's nearly Christmas days did you know
it's nearly Christmas I've been trying
to forget that well we've just moved
into a new office so we're currently in
a very incomplete studio so if you're
wondering why it's echoing or why
there's all these boxes on the floor
then yeah just just try not to pay
attention to that however we do still
have a love for fallout that hasn't gone
away Yeah right and a love for plastic
tap as well so all plastic that's true
that's laughs so we're gonna go through
our fall out Christmas list of things we
already own but you don't yet yeah if
there's a fallout 4 lover in your life
and you don't want them to hate you at
Christmas buying this stuff because
that's what Christmas is about men with
automatic Christmases please don't hate
me here's a gift so first up because I'm
holding it we've got this sexy christmas
jumper i'm going to unfold it shuffle
the detail so it's a nice dark blue
which is the color of no it's not the
kind of the vaults to it's it's a muse
blue enough yeah but it does say merry
Christmas from Bolton ok let's go share
relation radiation arms has got yellow
and blue my give you guys fall out it's
got probably some rad stay yeah plus
costs 10 rather this dude yeah what else
five charisma yeah yeah you reckon go
into a shop with that one over like whoa
half-price day if I get more charismatic
right now yeah wisma take all my things
please awesome let me go then improve my
stats I'm gonna post on stuff on you
right next up let's just get rid of your
face I rest the video we've got this I
can you buy this we've got some things
for video purposes maybe never got to
use them but if you want to look
absolutely terrifying yeah they're
really creepy nomas like in a horror
film for a tight shirt caricature of
Donald Trump haha the hairs better what
mine are Donald's
I'm actually gonna wear that because
it's super hot super hot we've also got
this the story the history story my
story you don't want to know the story
that would you do it I just know it's
serious fallout you've got things like
robots and computers you got house
characters there I'm Tosh yeah so three
easy ah one of those fallout pretenders
it's only played fallout 4 and you don't
want anyone to know just read this and
you can pretend like you've known it all
along you could be like oh yeah this is
like that time in New Vegas which was
released in october two thousand ten
whom that half good times what are you
yeah hey I'm no pretender but it is a
good book yes I'll read it anyway we've
also got this yeah I don't know is this
custom custom made but you can get
things like this unlike sites like Etsy
that those sort of things but make it
yourself no my wife's got sediment Bunty
don't drink it though don't I mean the
nuka-cola count was a nice touch yeah I
don't pop it and chug one of these down
it's not a percent sure it's poisonous
our next thing is the pop figures now I
quite like these I've got a couple
myself and if some people have loads I
don't know some people hate them but
look at these guys I think that's all I
one's pretty cool cue the noise yeah
they don't look nearly as creepy and
terrifying as a lot of them do yeah I
mean it's cuz that human the ones that
aren't human tend to sometimes look a
bit scary what are you doing yeah that's
it I don't know here it's a volt boy
bobblehead just like the ones in the
game I can't if I hold this because it's
a Chrismukkah pet my charisma is gonna
go to hi dua or the sweater and the
Volquez
I think we should a good vault boy put
the mask on him this mouse is so big and
there we go got boy ception so our next
one let's look at the pit boy I'm gonna
come around the front yeah ya popped our
bad boy open so here we go yeah
originally like oh we're readiness of
this because you can't actually buy them
again now really yeah they're all the
back and stock on on amazon yeah you
will have to pay a few caps of them but
if you're desperate for a variant pitboy
so you can see it's not a lovely sort of
vomit brown plastic finish just like the
real thing I've actually got my phone in
here at the moment it's on demo mode so
you don't have it hooked up all the
little dials move I mean they don't do
anything because they're plastic but
they do move so you can pretend and you
can see it's got a little light you guys
which on and off it comes on on the top
I think I need to wear it so I can check
my my stats ok let me just let me turn
the radio to cut off tip no it doesn't
turn off I'm afraid but there you go get
some diamond city jeans let me go you
want to open up our next bit of I do so
Luke rate is a subscription service I
don't know how much it is a month
because I've never had it but we have
people in the office you do and every
month you get a B old box full of just
some generic geek stuff yeah then every
now and again they do the legendary
boxes yeah themed these 14 there's a
mass effect one and there's a fallout 1
so we're going to open it when I sorts
inside whoa it's really big and you can
see it's that it's designed on the
inside so we've got a fridge once you
once you're done with it maybe you can
turn it inside out yeah that's the
that's the whole idea keep all your loop
in you it's genius broken ask me feel
free so first up we've got who's this
guy [__] me what's that don't unwrap
them oh yeah we go suffocate
there he is now you can see he's
actually got goggles and a little scarf
on if you haven't already done that in
the game it's google yeah you can make
him wear goggles and scarves so this is
actually it's just telling you what you
should be doing in the game as well as
demonstrating dr. grey mushy and a
tutorial tutorial Lex Utah I seen this
supposed to it comes in a little tube
which you can use for what he needs
tubes for throwing in the bin a few TV
poster I'm growing in the bin making
Christmas decorations out with probably
I don't know so there's two posters in
here the first is a nice pin-up girl and
nuka cola and her bum got my nose done
good bum dog me approved don't me and
then we have a sort of nice little art
rendering of your little red rocket
right back east edge it's a bit
different because I don't have this many
tools in mind so you spread the normal
because research are scarce this guy
doesn't care about resources it's just
like I just want it to look pretty we've
got coasters your beer and your
nuka-cola must have a look at them how
many do you think are in here for four
you know that though yes haha opened
this before so they come in tissue paper
which again you can repurpose into
something Christmasy probably got the
first one is nil oh boy oh boy he's
giving you the thumbs up because he
approves with your drinking problem
mm-hmm then we have you have become
addicted Oh 111 well it's good for you
sometimes to serve listen to that
message this is what 111 so you don't
even have to use this as a coaster you
can put on your door and everyone will
know that inside your room it's loads a
dead before our next one is the sexy
nuka-cola lady doesn't have a bum out
quite as much this time and
disappointing you disappointed over yeah
talk me dog me I wish her gone
everything was bummed themed actually
bum loot crate and then I last one is
volt tech industries which again you
could put on your door and everyone
would know that you're an evil person
who do experiments on people
yeah oh that's why it's in to my door I
was going we've got this one's really
hard to open a collector's pin set so I
did actually see someone wearing this
these ones at the launch party so I
guess they must have had the loot crate
maybe they were wearing this one which
is their Brotherhood of Steel I know
these things because i have read the
book you've got a little vault 111 1
just there got a red rocket one and you
got that guy again like I just gonna be
covered in small pictures of mole boy
yeah he's my BAE is that what the kids
say sbobet he's my face um okay so now
we have what's this gonna be I think
it's an apron is an apron oh it's
definitely funny it's not as a flag as a
network you could use his name friend oh
it's really big oh goodness okay you
hold that side there we go brother of
Steel yeah Brotherhood steel where we
are blue I like it it's good right so
you could use it as a flag you'd use it
as an apron you could repurpose it into
Christmas decorations movie what's if
you want it to break everything down its
paw paw so that's nice now we're gonna
work through you're gonna have as a cape
yeah see you see you could have it as a
cape I was just imagining like a little
thing coming up in the corner like
palliative dance didn't like that stop
using his flag run me disrespecting the
Brotherhood good okay I think I splits
my favorite bit it's a hoodie do you
want wear it I'll drape it around you
well it was actually been good on okay
now you've got that on one last bit of
kit what so this one is our final piece
of loot crate kit
mmm it's a bag I need that because I'm
I've encumbered keep all this stuff in
it's got a big flap and a little clip on
the front and then it's got a hole
inside like most bags do where you put
things and it's got this for pens
thought it is you can put pens in here
right in the front because people still
write with pens right I don't know are
you sure you don't us make scrap plans
into Christmas decorations pens are like
junk in fallout yes so that wouldn't be
entirely ridiculous so don't make fun of
me I need that put those dog okay though
I can go to vault school fault school
okay so Luke rate on the floor what's
her last thing it's big oh good hit
sweet i'll be back in one eye open this
is a part of their promotional campaign
but they still buy big crates of these
on Amazon yeah I actually went to go and
look at a healthy other day and my
housemates which they now our client
come in come in would you like a beer I
was like oh it and then they got these
other fridge knows like am I being
tested it's like am I still work so I
didn't have one but very bold dwellers
above 18 / yes are allowed to have yeah
I think I think it would be remiss if we
didn't try what you wanna okay you tried
one before yeah but like not ten three
in the morning I'm Evan don't tell
everyone that it's drinking time
somewhere okay yeah they're not cold
they are room temperature we should have
left them outside it's very cold outside
that's definitely be a funny taste
better than yes my Christmas but it is
better than the ones you're gonna find
in the wasteland so definitely beer
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to use the hashtag GS fallout on twitter
if you want to send us any of your
fallout community stuff we'd love to see
it you can also drop it in the comments
if you want and remember to follow us
both on Twitter I am at how not to draw
I'm at the regular days you can follow
us both and we're great and you should
thanks for watching we'll see you next
week Stacey by their wastelanders gross
human
that's impressive I think what real
quick oh my god ah well